an exclusive television interview a
former McDonald's employee tells us why
she's suing the fast-food giant over
sexual harassment Jenna Reese filed a
proposed class-action lawsuit yesterday
against McDonald's and one of its
michigan franchises the lawsuit comes
about a week after the company's CEO
Steve Easterbrook was fired for having a
romantic relationship with a subordinate
employee our investigative correspondent
that's Anna Warner spoke to Reese who
says she repeatedly asked for help from
a supervisor but she was ignored I
started there and pretty much instantly
he started getting harassed Jenna Reese
says the harassment began in fall 2017
at this McDonald's franchise in Mason
Michigan where she worked as a $14 an
hour manager she says in her lawsuit an
unnamed co-worker there frequently
grabbed her body parts including her
crotch breasts and buttocks
it started off little like words calling
me names and then it you know escalated
into touching and grabbing I was pushed
I was hit multiple times
she says staff even gave the man a
nickname the minor violator does that
mean what I think it means yeah I mean
yeah I mean he was constantly touching
not just me underage employees all the
time 32 year old Reese is one of at
least 50 workers from around the country
who have filed sexual harassment
complaints or lawsuits over the past
three years Reese's lawsuit says it's
indicative of a sexually hostile work
environment and the company culture that
enables it Reese says she complained to
the restaurants general manager multiple
times but was ignored
she quit McDonald's this past March in
part she says due to a disturbing
incident he came up to me and he put his
privates in my hand while I was in the
middle of making food like that was kind
of enough for me the franchise owners
did not respond to our request for
comment in an e-mail McDonald's says
it's committed to a safe and respectful
workplace the company established a
reporting hotline in
jeune enhanced its policies against
discrimination harassment and
retaliation and introduced new training
but franchisees who own 95% of
McDonald's u.s. restaurants aren't
required to offer the training
McDonald's is a company that needs a
culture change Mary Joyce Carlson is a
labor lawyer who represents women suing
McDonald's the minimum wage worker the
low-wage workers are not visible and
those people deserve to be paid a living
wage and to be safe on Tuesday we spoke
publicly at a demonstration in Detroit
together we have a voice like I was
alone and nobody was fighting for me so
hopefully people realize that they can
come forward and they won't they won't
be alone anymore for CBS this morning
Anna Warner Detroit serious allegations
yes about she's speaking up and now
people are paying attention yeah I hope
some of these franchisees owners pay
attention as well well I mean as the to
the point of the attorney made its if
you're a minimum wage worker you feel
pretty powerless in a situation yeah
hard to imagine she's the only one with
allegations like this